a very funny man you dress so well you
look amazing all the time I love the
hats the hats look fat that I always
thought you look great in the headband
you know I don't think I can you know I
have a problem with hats is that I have
a huge head and it's hurt seriously I go
to hat stores and they usually can't
find a hat that will fit me yeah yeah
that's yeah I mean because what is like
an eight nine eight let us know number
with Jim you had to give it an
adjustable yeah you know when you get
the adjustable trucker hats they don't
work the measurement they use for
planets I think I brought you a head I
wanted to see you brought me a hat I
thought this would be a KOCO cool and
snazzy hat let me just know let me tell
you I doubt this is gonna fit because I
look at it really okay I look at it it
feels like it's no no
I totally didn't think about the size
thing I'm sorry this is a hipster
yarmulke you think there's a little bit
of the hair of your forward like that
yeah gotta make somebody a cool a cool
whiskey drink man what do you need pal
what are you doing looks more like a
bonnet on it it looks like a bonnet
you're right Andy's right it does look
like I'm skipping through the lane
wearing flowers will you wait for word
you kind of made it cool when you
brought it down like over the I forget
[Music]
let's see the profile he's left 40% of
his head uncovered it was a very nice
gesture
I miss the size count